Spitzkunnersdorf im südöstlichsten
Zipfel der Republik eine
strukturschwache Gegend große
Unternehmen sucht man hier vergebens
Sebastian Herzog ist landfleischer in
vierter Generation er hat gerade Post
vom Stromversorger bekommen der Abschlag
steigt ab Januar von 1800 auf 8000 € pro
Monat trotz strompreisbremse dann müsste
das Kühlhaus hier fünfmal so voll hängen
damit man fünfmal so viel verkaufen
können und das ist unrealistisches
unrealistisch
ihn ärgert der strompreisdeckel der
greift bei kleinen und mittelständischen
Unternehmen erst bei 40 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde ja wir wissen ja nicht
mal was bedeuten die 40 Cent sind die
Umlagen dabei ist brutto ist es netto
was ist das der reine Arbeitspreis
und egal wie es ist trotzdem das
Vielfache von dessen was wir jetzt
bezahlen die Industrie
zahlt oder soll nur 13 Cent zahlen und
da steht für uns natürlich ein großes
Fragezeichen warum die Handwerker und
die kleinen Unternehmen wieder separat
betrachtet werden
der Fleischer spart Energie wo es geht
moderne Maschinen blockkraftwerk
Photovoltaik mehr sei nicht drin 15
Mitarbeitende beschäftigt Herzog erhofft
sie irgendwie halten zu können wir
wollen ja unser Geschäft trotzdem
fortführen und unterhalten und
eigentlich auch wieder ein Stück
nach der coronazeit ausbauen aber
natürlich mit den
Gegebenheiten die momentanen herrschen
wird es natürlich nicht einfach oder die
Frage besteht ob es überhaupt irgendwie
weitergeht wie geht es weiter auf die
Frage muss Bundeswirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck Antworten geben Anfang
November sein antrittsbesuchen Sachsen
einziges Unternehmen das er besucht ist
der chemie-riese wacker wir fragen nach
Arbeitsplätzen die verloren gehen
könnten wegen der hohen Energiepreise
der Minister antwortet ausweichend ich
verstehe jeden jede Sorge jede
Bedrängnis die Menschen und die
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer in
diesem Land im Moment tragen aber die
ökonomische Fahrtrichtung wenn man sich
die globalen Märkte anschaut ist
eindeutig eindeutig festzustellen
nämlich die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit wird
sich über zukünftige Märkte und
zukünftige günstige erneuerbare
Energieproduktion darstellen insofern
sind alle eingeladen damit zu machen
diese Einladung nutzt einem
landfleischer aus der Lausitz relativ
wenig Sebastian Herzog war dabei als
Robert Habeck in Dresden zum runden
tischlud sein Fazit ernüchternd also ich
denke das wird in der großen Politik so
nicht wahrgenommen was das kleine
Handwerk und die kleinste Unternehmen
leisten und auch an Arbeitsplätzen zu
Verfügung stellen und letztendlich
gerade im in Deutschland das
Lebensmittelhandwerk Becker Fleischer
ist eigentlich in Kulturerbe das wird ja
gerade
zunichte gemacht
bittere Worte und womöglich die harte
Erkenntnis dass die Regierenden nicht
jedem helfen werden die staatlichen
Hilfsprogramme seien als Überbrückung
gedacht nicht mehr nicht weniger die
Unternehmen dürfen sich jetzt auf keinen
Fall in Sicherheit wiegen und Denken
naja das Start hilft uns jetzt also und
der wird uns dann auch weiterhelfen weil
irgendwann sind die Preise wieder so
hoch und wer diese Zwischenzeit jetzt
nicht dazu nutzt in energiesparende
Technologien zu investieren oder
auch neue produktionsfelder zusätzlich
zu erschließen die dann eben nicht so
Energie intensiv sind also den ist
nichts zu helfen die liegen dann halt
nicht jetzt sondern eben in einem Jahr
aus dem Markt raus
Mülsen bei Zwickau hier hat die Firma
mrh reifenentsorgung ihren Sitz sie
recycelt alte Autoreifen daraus
entstehen Sportmatten und Unterschichten
von Kunstrasen wir brauchen also dort
große Werkzeuge große Pfeffermühlen um
überhaupt dort in zerkleinerungsprozess
instand zu kriegen das kostet jede Menge
Energie
Jahresstromverbrauch fast 5 Millionen
Kilowattstunden bislang zahlt das
Unternehmen viereinhalb Cent pro
Kilowattstunde ab Januar sind es 13 dank
strompreisbremse Geschäftsführer Danny
Schwalbe ist zufrieden mit den
politischen Beschlüssen
vor 70 Prozent des vorjahresverbaus
damit haben wir erstmal für diese 70%
eine gewisse Planungssicherheit
Planungssicherheit auch für die 65
Mitarbeitenden Kurzarbeit Streichung der
Nachtschicht Entlassungen soll es nicht
geben für die nähere Zukunft gibt er
sich gar optimistisch
ja für uns als Unternehmen haben
beschlossen in alternative Energien zu
investieren werden Photovoltaik weiter
ausbauen bei uns am Standort das wird
nicht reichen bei dem Verbrauch und
werden auch noch im Wind Energie
investieren so dass wir versuchen in
zwei bis drei Jahren mit der Firma hier
direkt zu sein im Erzgebirge sind nur
wenige so hoffnungsvoll
unternehmerproteste in Annaberg-Buchholz
die Krise sehen Sie hier als Bedrohung
nicht als Chance
die Regierung meiner Meinung nach uns zu
spät reagiert
Protest auch in der Lausitz gegen die
hohen Energiepreise 700 Handwerker und
Kleinunternehmer im Autokorso durch enge
Straßen die große Politik denken immer
an die kleinen Leute
so das ist eigentlich das Hauptproblem
es sind die Sorgen und Nöte auf den
Straßen und Marktplätzen des Landes
Angst das morgen der Arbeitsplatz weg
ist auch wenn unklar ist ob es wirklich
so kommt die Unternehmen werden sehr
genau Dich das Anschauen ist es
tatsächlich eine gute Idee sich von
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern zu
trennen weil angesichts der Fachkräfte
Situationen ist sehr schwierig sein wird
dann wieder die Beschäftigung
hochzufahren insofern erwarten wir auch
in einer solchen Situation nicht eine
riesengroße Entlassungswelle aber
punktuell in einigen besonders
betroffenen Bereichen wird das dann
natürlich auch zu
beschäftigungsverlusten führen
Lößnitz im Erzgebirge die örtliche
Gießerei deren Betrieb braucht Unmengen
an Gas und Strom durch regenerative
Energien nicht zu ersetzen das
Unternehmen ist größter Arbeitgeber im
Ort 85 Familien arbeiten für und leben
von der Gießerei das könnte bald vorbei
sein
das klingt jetzt erstmal nicht viel das
85 Familien aber es ist wirklich 85
Familien aus dem Ort ja dass wir prägen
den Ort haben die Geschichte des Ortes
geprägt aber es nach 85 Mitarbeiter die
dann wirklich die Tradition nicht mehr
leben können in der Gießerei wird Gas in
immensen Größenordnungen verbrannt denn
alles hier ist pure Energie
jeder weiß dass diese Themen die gerade
brisant sind uns maßgeblich eins zu eins
betreffen ja mit 17 Millionen Kilowatt
an Energie im Jahr sind natürlich
maßgeblich betroffen von dieser Krise
der Gaslieferant hat ihm bereits vor
Wochen die alten Verträge gekündigt neue
Verträge gibt es nicht
Jankowski muss deshalb am teuren
Spotmarkt Gas Einkaufen die nun
beschlossenen Staatshilfen von mehr als
200 Milliarden Euro würden für die
Gießereien Lößnitz kein einziges Problem
lösen
meine große Frage an der HPK ist ob er
wirklich eine
wettbewerbsfähige Gießereiindustrie im
Jahr 2025 hier in Deutschland noch sieht
momentan sehe ich diese nämlich nicht
weil ich nicht sehe dass ein Konzept
dahinter steht nicht sehe dass die
Situation im Wirtschaftsministerium im
Griff ist Gas und Strom werden wohl nie
wieder so günstig sein wie vor dem Krieg
in der Ukraine der deutschen Politik
fällt es schwer trotz aller
entlastungspakete eine Wahrheit
auszusprechen nicht alle Unternehmen
werden diese Krise überleben auch wenn
der Bundeskanzler etwas anderes
versprochen hat you never walk alone
niemand wird allein gelassen